[Music]
we're live from Los Angeles fyodor gold
the most famous and celebrated author in
America today
this is Shelley stone my scumbag
mistress come back to you you own a
novel where the protagonist is a
homeless serial killer it's inspired
please do not buy this book unfinished
writing books that sell only to
Hollywood from now on I'm gonna write
literature I'm gonna write for myself
[Music]
you go to your Kundalini and your
meditation every morning what kind of
man are you
I think I'm onto something exciting so
into it it was so good
very Ted Gold really really famous
successful hack author you are so
cynical oh it's not about cynicism - art
- integrity this is velocity she is a
great artist this hot new actress
velocity made television history she's
not interested in money
yesterday I was staging meaningful
performances with maybe 35 people and
today I'm a national sensation what does
it say about our culture this girl is a
cross between Isadora Duncan and Lady
gaga
you forgot mother Teresa let's make some
money on this before that forget 15
minutes are up bank accounts frozen what
I'm homeless sound like some Karma's
catching up to you man oh yeah
[Music]
you live in a sick world I gotta like it
it's pretty amazing what a difference a
day makes so what happened to integrity
you used me I'm an artist that's what we
do
have you forgotten life is always in
flux knowing that we can remake
ourselves every single day what a long
strange trip it's been
[Music]
you